when the rest of the media and many in
the congress were either
ignoring or making excuses for the riots
we saw for months in this country we
came out on the air almost every night
and told you we oppose political
violence of all kinds
on january 6th was political violence at
the capitol and we opposed that
but one thing that we oppose every bit
as much is the destruction of the civil
liberties that make this
america make it a country you would want
to live in
now that point used to be
uncontroversial particularly on the left
but now
outside a handful of principled mostly
far left figures none of the
self-described liberals in the congress
will say this out loud instead they're
moving in the other direction at high
speed
democrats are rushing to embrace a new
surveillance state
in the wake of the january 6th
insurrection using that day as a pretext
for creating say
a new secret police force not making
that up we told you about this last
night and we mentioned specifically a
member of congress from illinois
a character called brad schneider
schneider says he'd like to pass
something called the domestic terrorism
prevention
act apparently brad schneider was
watching last night as you hear his
reply ask yourself
is this the guy you want in charge of
preventing
domestic terrorism here's how he
responded quote do i want to see
increased monitoring of the types of
violent extremist domestic terrorists
that attack the capital
leaving five people dead including a
police officer absolutely
the real question is why tucker carlson
is okay with their deaths
right so if you have questions about
handing
brad schneider whoever that guy is the
keys to your country
voiding the bill of rights because brad
schneider demands that you do
after the insurrection on january 6th
then you're for killing police officers
you want people to die
and maybe you need your civil liberties
taken away
we'll see now if this all sounds
familiar
it is because every time something
horrible happens
creepy little demagogues like brad
schneider rush to the microphone and
tell you i'm sorry you can't be free
anymore it happened after 9 11.
9 11 what does it have to do with
january 6th it seems like kind of an odd
comparison
in fact so disproportionate it's
laughable and offensive to the 3
000 people who died on 9 11. but members
of congress were invoking anyway by the
way from both
parties in the same briefing where brad
schneider gave his stupid and scary
opinions another member of congress
a former fbi agent called brian
fitzpatrick said we must
adopt the same attitude toward domestic
terrorism
that we had toward al qaeda after 9 11.
when you look at what our response was
to 911 we said never again
we created a brand new uh department a
secretary level
uh position in the cabinet and an entire
new department
the department of homeland security we
took a lot of steps
to make sure that we were going to say
never again were we going to experience
something like 9 11.
we need to have that same never again
attitude towards domestic terrorism
because both are an equal threat what
who is this guy why is he in congress we
think he's a republican by the way who
cares
that's insulting what happened on
january 6 was on videotape
you saw it it was bad we denounced it
we'll denounce it again and every day
because who cares we feel that way
but to compare that to 9 11. if you're
saying that with a straight face
you're a liar and you have an agenda
that should make all of us nervous
but a lot of them do another congressman
luke correa admitted that the
domestic terrorism prevention act is
just the beginning
there's a lot more domestic spying to be
done he promised
this is the first step in a long
procession of actions we have to take
to make sure we address the issue
of other americans terrorizing
other americans in this great country
yeah okay the next step in a long
procession
of actions okay let's just be completely
clear
unlike the many of the people you see
calling for new secret police force
to be created we're against all
political violence
but no matter how much of it occurs we
are still americans we were born here we
have the right to say
whatever we believe period you cannot
abridge that right
we have the right not to be spied on by
our own government
for having political opinions that
people in power disagree with
period and anyone who tries to take
those rights away is a
far greater threat to this country than
anyone who showed up on the capitol
on january 6th period and
everybody should say that because it's
true and it would be true if the roles
were reversed and the other party was
impact doesn't matter
these are immutable undying principles
that form the basis
of american history and culture and life
and when they cease to be at the center
of our national life
you ought to leave because it's not
worth living a country like that